je suis un vieux de la grande interview
de notre invité ce soir c'est Jean-Louis
Vollandes président de la commission des
affaires étrangères à l'Assemblée
nationale bonsoir Jean-Luc boulange
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
évidemment l'actualité est extrêmement
forte il y a demain ça fera un an que la
Russie a déclaré la guerre à l'Ukraine
on a assisté à un choc frontal hier et
avant-hier entre Joe Biden le président
américain qui a fait une visite surprise
à Kiev qui a été à Varsovie et il est
encore aujourd'hui il a rencontré
différents membres de l'OTAN et Vladimir
Poutine qui a fait son discours très
très virulent vis-à-vis de l'Occident et
qui vient de prononcer ces mots tout à
l'heure dans un stade rempli à Moscou il
a dit la Russie combat actuellement sur
cette terre historiques d'abord une
première question ce choc frontal est-ce
qu'il ou est-ce que où est-ce qu'il va
nous emmener
écoutez c'est la réponse est difficile à
formuler parce que ce choc frontal il a
une origine et une seule c'est la
détermination du président Poutine de
remettre en cause tous ces accords
internationaux les frontières de
l'Ukraine qui dont l'indépendance avait
été solennellement proclamé et garantie
par les accords de Budapest avec en
contrepartie l'abandon des armes
nucléaires par les par les
ukrainiens et il a il y a un an pensant
faire une opération de quelques jours
pour empocher la souveraineté
ukrainienne il s'est lancé dans une
opération dont il voit bien aujourd'hui
qu'elle est en réalité sans issue et
qu'elle coûte extrêmement cher et la
seule façon de s'en sortir pour lui mais
il n'y ait pas du tout prêt c'est de
reconnaître son erreur et de laisser
l'Ukraine vivre conformément à la charte
des Nations Unies international on n'est
pas du tout
de notre côté il y a pas un affrontement
il y a simplement l'idée que un pays
souverain libre
garantit internationalement quand il
organise sa défense pour préserver son
indépendance mérite et c'est d'ailleurs
conforme à la charte des Nations Unies
d'être aider Milan militairement pour
mener la libération de son territoire
donc nous nous sommes simplement dans
une attitude défensive et d'ailleurs
reconnaissons que depuis le début
c'est-à-dire depuis la fin la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
depuis le début de la guerre froide
l'OTAN a toujours eu une posture
totalement défensive et jamais offensive
je sais que certains ne leur
reprochaient les Hongrois en 56 les
checks en 69 les Polonais 10 ans plus
tard non on a toujours été extrêmement
prudent on défend les les pays qui sont
membres de l'OTAN contre une attaque
éventuelle et quand un état qui n'est
pas membre de le temps et est attaqué
nous lui fournissons les moyens
nécessaires pour défendre cette son
territoire et maintenant nous le voyons
bien et c'est très clair dans le
discours de Poutine pour défendre aussi
notre système de valeurs qui est
directement mis en cause le maître du
Krema démocratie sont en danger ah oui
écoutez je pense que je pense que quand
on regarde la situation telle qu'elle
s'était créée au lendemain de
l'effondrement du mur de Berlin et de la
dislocation de l'Union soviétique on
avait une illusion pas tout le monde moi
j'avais été assez épargné par cette
illusion étant d'une école réaliste
plutôt on avait eu l'illusion que les
grands principes qui étaient les nôtres
la liberté la démocratie le pouvoir du
peuple l'État de droit la séparation des
pouvoirs le respect de la souveraineté
tout ce qui forme la base de la Charte
des Nations Unies allait se répandre
partout on a été de déboire allez boire
on a vu avec daesh que l'islamisme peut
résister on a ensuite vu que les
machines
renforcer une dictature impitoyable sur
un fond capitaliste on a vu après que la
Russie remettait en cause les
engagements qu'elle avait pris 20 ans
plus tôt et nous voyons bien que nos
principes même en Afrique sont rouges
donc nous avons eu des échecs en
Afghanistan alors qu'on défendait des
choses le droit des femmes des choses
qui sont vraiment auxquelles nous
croyons comme le sang
j'en tire comme le son que j'en tire
comme le sens que semble-t-il les
Français ne sont pas tout à fait prêts à
en tirer actuellement c'est que les
temps vont être durs que il faut
effectivement se préparer à des
confrontations qu'on espère pacifiques
mais qu'on ne gagnera pas si on n'est
pas mobilisé résolu déterminé à faire
les efforts nécessaires vous redoutez
une extension du conflit on voit bien
qu'il y a des thèses des hypothèses des
thèses ici ou là est-ce que vous y
croyez vous qui est un homme réaliste
pour reprendre votre impression
c'est difficile de prévoir exactement ce
que le président Poutine veut faire mais
ce qui est certain c'est que notre
attitude à l'ouest est extrêmement
claire et extrêmement prudente je crois
d'ailleurs que les Américains ont eu une
attitude assez bonne depuis le début de
ce conflit on dit
l'Ukraine défend sa souveraineté
l'Ukraine défense et valeur qui sont les
nôtres nous devons l'aider à mener ce
combat mais nous ne voulons en aucun cas
une extension du conflit le temps
n'interviendra jamais sur le territoire
russe et nous invitons nos partenaires
Ukrainiens nos amis Ukrainiens à ne pas
porter la guerre sur les territoires
russes alors maintenant si Monsieur
Poutine veut véritablement ce que je ne
crois pas en profondeur veut déchaîner
une guerre générale vous savez c'est
celui qui veut se battre on porte
toujours la décision contre celui qui
veut pas
plusieurs questions pour réagir aux
propos que vous n'êtes tenir d'abord
est-ce que le déplacement de Joe Biden à
Kiev en Ukraine déplacement surprise
est-ce que c'est le retour des
États-Unis du président américain sur le
théâtre européen oui je crois que c'est
important parce que on avait accrédité
non seulement Trump mais également
on avait accrédité l'idée du pivot c'est
d'ailleurs la situation est calme du
côté des des Russes et l'ennemi
principal c'est le chinois c'est
Monsieur psy il faut mettre
comment ça c'est toujours un peu ce qui
se passe justement on a accrédité cette
idée et ensuite on a dit bah écoutez
pour Biden et pour les États-Unis il y a
une diversion Poutine maladroitement a
remis les États-Unis en sel à réactiver
un conflit qui n'aurait jamais dû voir
le jour donc il y a une sorte de de
distraction des américains qui sont
obligés de se concentrer sur la Russie
en fait ce que signifie le voyage de
Monsieur Biden c'est que l'engagement de
la défense de l'Europe occidentale
Ukraine comprise est un engagement
majeur pour les États-Unis et que les
États-Unis restent fidèles à la ligne de
leur double engagement ils sont présents
sur l'océan Atlantique et sur la défense
de l'Europe et ils sont évidemment
présents sur le Pacifique avec toutes
les inquiétantes évolution autour de
Taïwan on a vu les déclarations et
encore tout récemment lors de la
conférence de sécurité à Munich du
président Macron est-ce que d'abord vous
trouvez sa ligne et celle qui le veut
que doit tenir la France et deuxième
question est-ce que ces choix
stratégiques géo stratégiques qu'a fait
le président de la République est-ce que
on aurait pu il aurait pu en parler
devant le Parlement puisque vous êtes
président la commission des affaires
étrangères je le rappelle à l'Assemblée
nationale
un congrès il pourrait le faire il a
fait ça deux fois le début du du son
premier quinquennat il a dû sans doute
trouver que la formule n'était pas très
adéquate c'est vrai qu'elle n'est pas un
peu difficile non parce qu'on sait pas
si on lui répond si on lui répond ça
peut être une mise en cause le président
n'est pas responsable devant le
Parlement là nous touchons à toute
l'ambiguïté du système institutionnel
français qui fait que le président est à
la fois un arbitre au-dessus des parties
et le chef réel de l'exécutif qui en
fait est responsable indirectement
surtout sur la diplomatie mais je pense
que sur le fond le président a fait un
très bon discours à Munich où il a
vraiment dit les choses qui sont où il
est en plein en plein accord avec
l'ensemble des partenaires et puis après
il a fait ses déclarations qui étaient
plus difficiles à comprendre auprès de
certains de vos confrères et consœurs et
là je crois qu'on ne doit pas on ne doit
pas donner le sentiment ce que ne donne
pas vraiment le président Macron mais ce
que donne par exemple le président
tchèque donnait le sentiment comme un
interlocuteur le lui a dit à Munich
d'avoir un peu peur de la victoire on
est engagé nous n'avons qu'une chose à
souhaiter c'est que les Ukrainiens
gagnent gagner ça veut pas dire envahir
la Russie ça veut dire simplement la
libérer mais ce que ce que suggère
Emmanuel Macron et qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est à partir du moment où
on ne veut pas porter la guerre contre
la Russie on n'est pas maître de choisir
notre interlocuteur le maître du kamelas
c'est pas comme avec Hitler ou on a
commencé par occuper Berlin et ensuite
on a dit bah on a eu Adenauer à la place
de d'Hitler c'était beaucoup mieux bon
non là c'est pas ça donc on choisit pas
notre âge agriculteur et ce que suggère
le président Macron et là je crois qu'il
a raison c'est que il faudra un moment
quel que soit et le moment n'est pas
venu assurément c'est avec le dirigeant
que les Russes mettront en face de nous
qu'on négociera or tout le monde
souhaite qu'à un moment ou un autre et
plutôt sera le mieux même si les
circonstances sont absolument pas réunis
aujourd'hui parce que on va pas
tellement le peuple russe se soulever et
j'ai marqué
en général le pool le pouvoir russe se
transforme se modifie de faire au profit
de gens très proches par exemple
Catherine II a commencé par tuer son
mari
Alexandre premier passe pour avoir
liquidé son père
khrouchchev à liquidée Beria qui était
son collègue au pôle public bureau donc
c'est plutôt des des petits
est-ce que la Russie a décidé donc de
suspendre sa participation au traité
nucléaire new start
a qualifié cette décision de grosses
erreurs est-ce que c'est
difficile de répondre mais est-ce que
Vladimir Poutine il est en train de dire
quelque chose ou alors il est dans la
rhétorique de guerre non je crois qu'il
y a de tout ce qui touche au nucléaire
Poutine aime bien l'agiter il estime que
dans le dans un certain nombre
d'opinions publiques notamment l'opinion
allemande ça fait un peu peur je crois
pas que ça signifie grand chose vous
remarquez que Monsieur Poutine n'a pas
dénoncé le traités il n'a pas dit il a
il a suspendu les mesures de de
surveillance réciproque il n'a pas dit
qu'il s'affranchissait des limites
puisque level traité ça consiste à
limiter le nombre de le nombre de de
missiles donc il a pas du tout dit qu'il
s'affranchissait de cela il a dit c'est
inadmissible dans l'état où nous sommes
des relations avec l'Amérique en plus
ils viennent surveiller nos armements
nucléaires client cela dit que il a le
même pouvoir sur le pouvoir américain
alors donc je crois que c'est vraiment
une mesure de gesticulation mais quand
même ceux qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on
voit de plus en plus dans ce monde les
armes nucléaires se développaient et les
mesures d'encadrement
baissé disparaître on avait trois
traités on avait traité anti balistique
vigiles qui remonte à la nuit des temps
à la guerre froide au milieu des années
70 qui a été dénoncé on a eu traité sur
les forces nucléaires intermédiaires là
qui a été dénoncé par les Américains
parce que les Russes non respectaient
pas les termes et maintenant on a la
suspension de start on a quand même un
retrait général de toute un ensemble de
moyens de régulation du conflit qui
souvent date de la guerre froide et ça
c'est quand même pas bon
faut-il aller plus loin justement de la
question se pose sur les armes fournies
à l'Ukraine
vous savez sur sur les chars sur l'aise
qu'il faut des avions moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de tout ça ce que je crois
c'est qu'on a intérêt à agir de façon je
crois qu'il y a trois trois mots d'ordre
il faut agir de façon coordonnée j'ai
pas du tout aimé cette cette fois tu me
donnes trois tu me donnes des des
Abrahams ou des ou des léopards ou de
non il faut compter il faut que ce soit
concerté il faut que ce soit massif et
il faut que ce soit rapide et ça et il
faut répondre discrètement efficacement
pleinement et de façon coordonnée est-ce
qu'il faut leur fournir des avions de
combat ecoutez ça moi je crois que tout
le monde tout le monde reconnaît deux
choses trois choses en fait un pour
l'instant les Ukrainiens contrôlent leur
espace aérien les Russes ne s'y
aventurent pas de les Russes contrôlent
leur espace aérien si on s'y aventurer
on perdrait beaucoup de matériel
deuxièmement les pilotes ne pas formé et
il faut donc il faut donc d'abord les
former et troisièmement ce qui compte le
plus aujourd'hui ce sont les l'hémiciles
les les les les
missiles et les et les chats les droits
il semble que les les Ukrainiens est
assez bien maîtrisé leur il pense que
c'est drone iranien ils étaient quand
même un peu un peu rudimentaires ils
étaient assez longs et il s'agissait
très directement et on pouvait il semble
militaire qui me disent ça moi je n'y
connais rien mais il semble que avec des
moyens classiques de DCA parce qu'on
appelait à Flac on arrive à en démolir
un très grand nombre la question
maintenant qu'on se pose c'est comment
ça fait un an de guerre en Ukraine on
voit bien que c'est pas terminé non du
tout qui a aucune pour l'instant il y a
rien sur la table il y a Poutine vient
de l'annoncer la visite ping en Russie
il y avait le chef de la diplomatie
chinoise qui se trouve en ce moment à
Mos et qui dit il a plein de paix est-ce
que la Chine peut en fait jouer les
arbitres dans ce dans ce conflit de ceux
qui pensent que la question de savoir
qui joue les arbitres et 13 secondaires
ce qui compte c'est savoir s'ils sont
capables de se mettre d'accord
ukrainiens et russe sur un projet et là
je rejoins votre recette d'ici mais je
ne vois pas tant qu'il y a une situation
d'équilibre militaire comment on peut
arriver à la paix on arrivera la paix si
les
Ukrainiens réussissent une offensive et
que les Russes sentent ils vont tout
perdre si négocient pas ou à l'inverse
si les Russes réussissent se renforcis
et c'est des ukaniens sont sont dans une
situation désespérée et c'est ça qu'il
faut éviter donc aidons les Ukrainiens à
avoir un rapport de force qui leur soit
favorable car c'est un rapport de force
nouveau qui seul permettra une
négociation de paix on va parler aussi
de est-ce qu'il faut de nouvelles
sanctions il y a eu un débat tout au jeu
aujourd'hui au sein l'Union européenne
pour savoir s'il fallait à est en train
de sanction ça fait un an de fonction
économique on voit bien que les
conséquences sont majeures voire
irrévocables dans certains secteurs
juste avant je voudrais revenir sur des
propos que vous avez tenu qui ont
suscité la polémique les questions
différentes après mais je voudrais que
vous revenez sur ces propos que vous
avez tenu je crois que c'était le
contraire de repas vendredi dernier vous
avez parlé
des derniers
actes nous suivent exactement les actes
vous avez parlé au début alors au début
de la franchise mais donc effectivement
c'est ressorti récemment sur
l'immigration qualifiée vous avez parlé
de l'immigration qualifiée à propos des
Ukrainiens qu'est-ce que vous avez voulu
dire est-ce que c'est des propos que
vous maintenez aujourd'hui bien sûr sauf
que c'est peut-être pas eu l'extension
la plus à droite mais c'est le type même
de la Fauque la fake
interprétation qu'est-ce que j'ai dit
les gens avaient peur de voir des
débarqué par centaines de milliers j'ai
dit ce sont des gens courageux et ils
pourront
nous ils s'installeront très bien alors
on a dit il dit ça parce que c'est des
blancs il dit il dirait pas la même
chose si c'était des Noirs pas de chance
j'avais dit exactement la même chose
trois semaines plus tôt des des gens de
Calais parce que quand je vois tous ces
gens qui de Calais qui ont traversé
toutes les mers les continents les
épreuves les plus terribles je dis que
s'ils viennent chez nous ce sera un
enrichissement pour la France c'est une
chance pour la France disait mon mon
vieil ami Mario Stasi c'est ça que j'ai
voulu dire alors on peut prendre les
propos les tordre dans tous les sens et
mais ça vous les avez rectifié
simplement il faut arrêter de de
pratiquer le soupçon systématique
essayer de savoir ce que quelqu'un veut
dire quand il dit quelque chose alors je
vais sanction voilà ça c'est ma deuxième
question
économique est-ce que pour vous les ont
fonctionné ou pas parce que on peut se
poser la question soit nombreux chef
d'entreprise qui ont décidé il y a avoir
il y a quelques jours je recevais en DVD
de semaine la Société Générale
évidemment qui a vendu la rose Bank
c'est le cas pour de nombreuses on se
pose la question de savoir si c'est
efficace est-ce que pour vous c'est
sanctions ont joué à un rôle important
on peut être
risque de faire fléchir Vladimir Poutine
ou pas du tout je crois que sur les
sanctions il faut il faut jamais
attendre des sanctions plus qu'elles ne
peuvent donner les sanctions c'est une
action à long terme d'abord c'est pas
une action à court terme je pense que et
deuxièmement je pense que le but n'est
pas tellement
d'affaiblir le le le le le l'économie
russe c'est d'empêcher de dégager les
technologies et les financements
nécessaires à la poursuite de l'effort
de la guerre donc je suis partisan de
sanctions très ciblées d'abord sur les
sur les personnes qui sont coupables par
exemple la discussion qui a eu lieu
aujourd'hui sur l'une des discussions
qu'il fallait s'il fallait sanctionner
le caoutchouc le nucléaire ça c'est pas
c'est l'essentiel en revanche on a
discuté de savoir s'il fallait frapper
de pénalité les gens qui se rendent
coupables de déportement de déportation
pardon d'enfants Ukrainiens là je crois
que ça mérite quand même qu'on passe un
petit effort si vous voulez on a on
assiste actuellement à des enlèvements
massifs d'enfants dans toutes les
provinces de l'Est prétendue prétendues
russes et en réalité
ukrainienne un enlèvement massif
d'enfants qu'on arrache à leur famille
qui ne revoit plus leurs parents et
quand on trouve et là ceux qui dans la
chaîne de commandement russe sont
coupables de de de de complicité dans
cette affaire mérite d'être sanctionné
maintenant les sanctions moi je crois
qu'il faut les sanctions financières
sont importantes les sanctions éner
seront fondamentales je crois que les
Russes qui ne produisent pas grand chose
d'autre que de l'énergie pour avoir
énormément de mal dans les 10 ans ou les
15 ans qui viennent à trouver des
clients pour pour leur énergie en
revanche il est vrai que à court terme
il semble que le latinte au PIB russe
étaient moins importantes qu'on ne le
penserait l'essentiel c'est d'aider
militairement lucrètes il y aurait faut
rester au conditionnel il y aurait
quelques divergences au sein de l'Union
européenne est-ce que on voit bien que
le soutien de l'opinion
occidentale à cette guerre et quelque
chose de très important et Valérie joue
beaucoup sur cette dans la démarche qui
joue beaucoup sur cet aspect là est-ce
que vous redoutez que les opinions
occidentales commencent à fléchir
d'abord sur les divergences il faut il
faut distinguer deux choses il y a
toujours un parti Léon roi etc qui sont
qui ont combattu les sanctions et puis
des discussions tout à fait normal sur
le plan technique de savoir quels sont
les sanctions les plus opportunes et là
ça discute alors c'est c'est le sur
l'opinion publique oui on voit c'est un
discutable il y a eu des sondages qui
ont été fait on voit que par exemple
la réprobation à l'égard de la Russie
reste intacte le soutien moral à
l'Ukraine reste intacte enfin un peu
baissé mais quand même très large en
revanche il y a une interrogation sur
l'aide au
l'envoi la livraison d'armes et là je
dis il faut être cohérent il faut être
cohérent on ne peut pas dire qu'on
soutient l'Ukraine et l'empêcher de se
défendre et assister comme ça à
l'extérieur à l'effondrement de ce PAL
vous savez la fameuse phrase qu'on
attribue à tort à bossuer Dieu se moque
des hommes qui
dénonce les conséquences de ce dont ils
chérissent les causes si vous vous aimez
l'Ukraine et des ukraines à se
comprendre c'est ça le grand message
alors effectivement les Français il faut
qu'ils se il faut qu'il se pénètre de
cette idée profonde que nous sommes
engagés tous dans un combat ou nos
valeurs sont essentielles la démocratie
l'État de droit le général de Gaulle
avait dit le succès le le succès coûte
l'effort la vie est un combat le succès
coûte l'effort et le salut exige la
victoire ces trois phrases elles doivent
rester notre mantra notre
juste un mot en ce moment se déroule
j'ai 20 finances en un on voit bien que
la gouvernance mondiale elle est mise à
mal aujourd'hui comment est-ce que
est-ce qu'on peut essayer de le qui est
susceptible de s'être fondation de mener
cette revendation c'est vrai qu'on a on
a quand même un univers qui est
complètement fragmenté brisé disloqué
avec des idéologies avec notamment cette
idéologie qui est la nôtre dont je ne
rougit donc je veux défendre l'idéologie
démocratique pacifiste juridique elle
est contestée par un certain nombre de
gens si on ne reconstruit pas un
consensus là-dessus on aura beaucoup de
mal à faire autre chose entre nous que
des accords pragmatiques et et à court
terme or si nous voulons résoudre le
problème gérer par résoudre mais gérer
le problème de la transition climatique
de la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique nous avons besoin de
mobiliser des ressources énormes sur le
plan financier nous avons besoin de
mobiliser des énergies de façon
convergente or aujourd'hui je n'aperçois
pas cette mobilisation à tous les
niveaux et je suis très inquiet sur ce
plan-là d'une façon générale chère
Edwige je suis préoccupé je suis inquiet
pas l'idée que ce que nous défendons
n'est pas suffisamment précisément prise
en compte par tout le monde nous sommes
dans un monde très dur très dangereux et
il faut retrouver les fondamentaux et
c'est fondamentaux c'est l'étape droit
la démocratie la solidarité entre les
peuples la volonté de et la volonté de
résister à toutes les barbaries et qui
nous sont opposés ça demande vous voyez
je suis toujours cette phrase de
tussidie qui est que que la devise de
commentaires il n'est pas de bonheur
sans liberté ni de liberté sans
vaillance bonheur liberté vaillance
c'est comme ça que nous nous en
sortirons espérons espérons espérons que
ça soit un chemin qui soit suivi merci
beaucoup je viens de voir l'ange avoir
été avec nous je rappelle vous êtes
président la commission des finances de
l'Assemblée nationale des modèles des
Affaires étrangères
nationales d'affaires étrangères pardon
à l'Assemblée nationale députée modem il
y avait plein de questions à vous poser
aussi parce que c'est passé le spectacle
qu'on a vu à l'Assemblée nationale mais
ça sera pour un autre
interview j'en suis ressorti absolument
affligé merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous tout de suite takenko si vous
voulez au revoir cette interview bien
sûr le replay et sinon vous pouvez
trouver le podcast et ça s'affiche
devant vous un petit QR code c'est sur
le site de BFM Business bonne soirée
tout de suite à